[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام ومرحبا بكم مره
اخرى بعد انقطاع فرضته تغطيه الاحداث في
السودان
الم تصبح المواجهه المباشره بين روسيا
والغرب قاب قوسين او ادنى الم تكسر امريكا
واوروبا اخر المحرمات مع الروس بعدما
اعلنتا عن تجويد اوكرانيا بطائرات حربيه
متقدمه
هل تصبح المدن الغربيه في مرمى الجيش
الروسي قريبا لماذا لا يبتعد الغرب من
سقوط باخموت قبل ايام في ايدي القوات
الروسيه وانهيار المقاومه الاوكرانيه بدل
تصعيد الوضع في اوكرانيا مع موسكو
لكن في المقابل الم يستطع ما يسمى
بالمجاهدين الافغان قبل عقود هزيمه روسيا
بصواريخ ستنجر الامريكيه البدائيه فما
بالك بطائرات امريكيه الان الا يشكل
الاعلان عن تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات اف 16
الامريكيه الرهيبه صدمه كبرى للجيش الروسي
الم تحصل المقاومه الاوكرانيه ايضا على
صواريخ بعيده المدى تطالب العمق الروسي
الم يتعرض حتى الكرملين قبل اسابيع لهجوم
بالطائرات المسيره كيف سيشعر الرئيس
الروسي لاحقا عندما يرى المدن الروسيه في
مرمى الطائرات والصواريخ الغربيه الفتاكه
اسئله اطرحها على الدكتور محمد فرج الله
رئيس تحرير وكاله انباء اوكرانيا بالعربيه
من كييف وعلى الدكتور نزار بوش استاذ
العلوم السياسيه من موسكو نبدا نقاش بعض
الفاصل
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس دكتور
نزار لو بدات معك من موسكو يعني بعد حوالي
14 شهرا من بدء الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا او
العمليه الروسيه الخاصه في اوكرانيا يبدو
ان كل المحرمات الغربيه قد سقطت ونعني
بالمحرمات انه يعني لم يعد هناك شيئا
محرما بالنسبه للمواجهه مع روسيا على ضوء
طبعا على ضوء
التفكير جديا هذه المره بتزويد اوكرانيا
بطائرات اف 16
الامريكيه بالاضافه طبعا الى صواريخ
بريطانيه بعيده المدى الى اكثر من 250
كيلو مترا من نوع ستورم شادو
كيف تفهمون هذه هذه الخطوه في في موسكو
الى اين الامور
نعم في حقيقه الامر جربت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مع بريطانيا مع الدول الغربيه
وحلف الناتو كل الاسلحه التي لديهم
وتزودوا بها النظام الاوكراني ولكن لم
يستطيعوا فعل شيء ولم يستطيعوا رد روسيا
ولا ان تخرج روسيا من الاراضي التي حررتها
من النظام النازي يعني دعنا نسلسل الامور
تتذكرون طائره برقدار كيف عملت حقيقه في
بدايه العمليه العسكريه لدى الاوكران يعني
عملت وحقيقه اثرت ولكن بعد مده قصيره بدات
كالعصافير تتساقط بعدها زود الغرب او
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الافضل نتحدث
لان الغرب تحت قياده الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه زودوا
ولكن بعد مده ايضا اصبحت هايمرز ايضا
كالعصافير والان بواسطه بواسطه الحرب
الالكترونيه الروسيه استطاعوا طبعا ان
يسقطوا هذه المنظومه وطبعا يخفف كثيرا من
فعالياتهم
ونتذكر ايضا الاسلحه الاخرى
ولنصل في نهايه المطاف الى اليوبارد والى
فادخلت روسيا 92 طبعا الاقوى في العالم
واستطاعت ان تسيطر على كل شيء
لنصل الى طبعا الصواريخ البعيده المدى كما
تفضلت انت
شادو يعني التي مداها اكثر من 250 كيلو
متر ربما الى 300 كيلومتر وبدات تسقط
واسقطت روسيا عده صواريخ منها لنصل اليوم
الى ان وطبع التي طبعا دمرتها روسيا منذ
اسبوع دمرت منظومه كامله واليوم واليوم
يتحدثون عن اف 16 انا اولا لم اتفاجا بذلك
وحتى لو طلب زيلينسكي ربما وهو يطلب في
الوقت الحاضر
باسلحه اسلحه نوويه او ذريه تكتيكيه طبعا
انا ربما يذهب الغرب المجنون الى هذه
الخطوه ولكن ماذا بعد هل سوف تتغير يعني
هل ستتراجع بالاحرى موسكو عن خطتها بازاله
هذه هؤلاء النازيين من اوكرانيا هل
تراجع روسيا عن اهدافها التي وضعتها من
خلال العمليه العسكريه لا على الاطلاق
روسيا مستمره مهما حشد الغرب على الاطلاق
على الاطلاق مهما حسد اخيرا اخيرا دكتور
فيصل
لدى روسيا ولادا روسيا والان تستخدم كل
اسلحه كثيره لم تستخدمها سابقا يعني وطبعا
انتم تعرفون سوء
ثلاثين وطبعا
31 كلها تتفوق على هذه الطائرات التي سوف
تصبح ايضا كالعصافير وتتساقط على الارض
الاوكرانيه وليس على الارض الروسيه هذا
اؤكده لكم القيادات العسكريه والمحللون
العسكريون الروسنا يتحدثون بهذه الصيغه
وبهذه اللهجه الروحيه دكتور محمد سمعت هذا
الكلام يعني يعني دكتور محمد يعني لماذا
كل هذا التطبيل والتزبير لطائرات امريكيه
جديده ستدخل المعركه في اوكرانيا ولصواريخ
بريطانيه والدكتور يقول لك لقد جربتم كل
شيء ولم يبقى امامكم الا النووي كيف ترد
عليه
دائره روسيه واحده دخول المجال الجوي
تتهاوك العصافير هذا اولا ثانيا ما يخص
قبل عام قبل عام الجيش الاوكراني بكل
شجاعه وبساله الحق طبعا الصفات بالجيش
الروسي صفعه تلك الاخرى والهزيمه تلك
الاخرى بدءا من شرنيكا
واما موضوع هايمرز
يقدم ولا دليل 16 فقط مش 160 16 منظومه
هايمرز قلبت كل موازين القوى وراينا كيف
تحرق المخازن الروسيه بالجنوب الاوكراني
روسيا التي ارادت ان تقول العالم بان
لديها منظومه صاروخيه الشمس الحارقه اين
هي هي الان عباره عن خرده في ضواحي كيف
وخا روسيا كانت تقول بان لديها الصواريخ
الكنشاط اوكرانيا اليوم تدخل التاريخ فقط
بمنظومتين باتريوت وانا هنا في كييف
الرابع من مايو دخل التاريخ الفي اول من
فرح عندما راى بان الباتريوت قادره على
ماذا على اسقاط صاروخ كنجال الذي تباها به
روسيا بوتين كثيرا والذي يفوق سرعته 12
طبعا سرعه الصوت ونرى الان روسيا لم يعدها
اي تفوق في مجال عسكري واليوم نرى والعكس
تماما الجيش الاوكراني عندما اثبت العالم
هذه روسيا لا تستحق ان تؤخذ بحائل الجد
هذه روسيا لا تؤخذ بانها دوله عظمى عندها
راى العالم وغير نوع التسليح وبدا الاصول
هنا طبعا في اليوبارد وتشالنجر اذا كان
الاوكرانيون بالدبابات القديمه الحق
الهزائم بالروس في الاقاليم المذكوره فما
بالك عندما دخول اسلحه متطوره مثل طبعا
والروس الان اصبحو يدقون ناقوس الخطر
عندما جاء للحديث عن اف 16 لماذا اف 16 هي
من الطائرات المقاتله معروفه عالميا تضرب
اهداف بدقه اليوم تناغم اف 16 مع منظومه
باتريوت يغلق السماء امام طبعا روسيا في
الثاني عشر من مايو روسيا قامت باكثر هجوم
صاروخي في السماء به سته صواريخ كنجال
اوكرانيا حولتها الى رماد بالليله الواحد
تخسر روسيا 200 مليون واليوم العالم يرى
بان هذه روسيا بفضل القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه لا يمكن ان تحمل بعد الجو الجد
لذلك بدا الحديث عن سلاح جديد دكتور فيصل
روسيا غادرت نادي الاقوياء روسيا اليوم
العالم لم يعد يرى بان روسيا الجيش
العثاني عالميا القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
على الارض اثبتت بكل ما قدمته روسيا من ان
سلاح انه لا قيمه له حتى ما يسمى طبعا من
الخوه العسكريه الروسيه سيد الكريم الخول
العسكريه الروسيه اليوم الاوكرانيون اجروا
عليها تجارب كلها من البلاس اما الغذاء
الغذاء الذي كان تقدمه القوات الروسيه
لجنودها بعضها وقع كغنائم باليد الاوكراني
تاريخ الصلاحيه انتهى 2015 الكلاب في
اوروبا لا يمكن ان تقدم لها طعام فاسد
روسيا تعامل واخرها قبل يومين عندما دخلت
مجموعه مسلحه من الروس تدربوا الاوكران
واليوم في اقليم بالجرد اليوم يقومون
بهزيمه تاريخيه لروسيا اربع قرى الان في
داخل روسيا تسيطر عليها قوات روسيا الحره
وجايين الروس كيف هربوا من طبعا احد لغه
الحدوديه اليوم الان كل ما كان يقوم عليه
يتحدث عنه من طبعا خذ حمراء لم تعد حمراء
اما الان ندخل مرحله اف 16 والصواريخ بعده
المدى سواء ستورم شادو ولا العلم هي طبعا
مداها من 250 الى 500 والمره الاولى
الاوكراني تمكنه من قصف
والمعسكرات اليوم روسيا عندما بدات الحرب
اوكرانيا كاتب امكانيتها اقل تواضعا ولم
تستطع روسيا ان تحسب المعركه فما بالك
روسيا بعدا عام من الحرب وهي منهكه وراينا
روسيا بالعرض الاخير لم يعد لديها رجال
العرض الاخير الجيش الروسي الذي شارك
بالعرض الاخير سعمايه اقل بخمس اضعاف مما
هو بوتن الان يعود بالخرده تي 34
للاستعراض في الساحه الحمراء في حين كان
سابقا يعرض دبابه ارماتا اين هي ارماتا
غير موجوده اين هو الكنجال اسقطه
الاوكرانيون اين هي الشمس الحارقه سقطت
اليوم ورقه التوت عن الجيش الروسي سقطت
وروسيا غادرت نادي الاقوياء واوكرانيا
الان تغير المعادله واليوم ما كانت العالم
يتعامل مع روسيا باعتبار معين وثقل سياسي
معين تبين بانه كله
طبعا مصطنعه وفبركه اضافه الى طبعا
التراشق في الداخل الروسي سواء ما بين
مرتزقه باجنر وبين القوات الروسيه واليوم
نرى العجز في الداخل الروسي ونرى الان
العالم ان اصبح ينظر الى اوكرانيا كاهميه
استراتيجيه كقلعه لحمايه اوروبا الشرقيه
لذلك الان روسيا بياناتها لا قيمه لها
تصريحاتها فيما يخص قصف السلاح كله انا
هنا بكيف لم يقصفوا شيئا لم يبقى لديهم
الا سلاح واحد وهو طبعا ما ياخذوه من
ايران من بعض الدرونات ويقسمون ماذا
يقتلون يقتلون طبعا الاطفال والان راى
الان النازيه في موسكو راى كيف حول الرؤى
النازيون الالمان مدمره النازيون الروس
رايناهم كيف فعلوا في باخموت جميل جدا
دكتور نزار كيف ترد
لا يعني بصراحه مسكين ضيفك الكريم حقيقه
مع الاسف انا اقول هذه الكلمه اولا لو ان
كل كلامه او هذا الكلام الذي تحدث به
حقيقه حقيقه لا استطاعوا ارجاع ضخموت او
بالروسي لا استطاعوا
يعني ارجاع اجزاء كثيره من من
محطه زباروجا لاستطاعوا لاستطاعوا لم
اقاطعك لم اقاطعك
فاعتقد هذا الكلام اتمنى ان هو الكلام
الذي تحدث به اتمنى ان يبقى يصدقه ويبقى
يصدقه طبعا القيادات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
لانهم مخدوعون حقيقه
روسيا يذهبون خطوه خطوه ويتقدمون خطوه
خطوه وبهدوء وبعقل وبعقل بارد وبعقل بارد
سيدمرون الاله العسكريه الغربيه المتطوره
ورايناهم هم بالمناسبه هم طبعا يصورون هذه
الفيديوهات ويعرضونها على الملا هم الذين
صوروا 32
صاروخ باتريو ضربوه او اطلاقوه على صاروخ
كنجال ولم يستطيعوا اصابه صاروخ انشاء
الواحد فماذا يتحدث ضيفك الكريم على كل
حال نحن على تواصل مع كيف بشكل يومي
بالمناسبه مع مع الشعب الاوكراني هناك
الذي لا يستطيع ان يتحدث ويقول كلمه واحده
مخالفه لقيادته طبعا بين قوسين قيادته
لزيلانسكي وزمراته وسنه سوف يكون
نزار نعم بس دكتور نزار طيب السؤال
المطروح السؤال الذي يعني يطرحه الشارع
الان
طيب هل يعقل ان منطقه صغيره مثل باخموت
منطقه صغيره البعض يقول قريه البعض يقول
مدينه باخر النهار هي منطقه يعني كم كلفت
الجيش الروسي وعصابات المرتزقه من ضحايا
ومن قتلى البعض يتحدث عن عشرات الالاف هل
يعقل ان ان تخسر عشرات الالاف من القتلى
الاوكرانيين
الذين
الروس من اجل هذه المنطقه الصغيره ثم كم
شهر كم شهر غرقت القوات الروسيه والقوات
المسانده لها في تلك البقعه الصغيره ونحن
لساتنا في بدايه انت تعلم يعني عندما دخل
الروس الى اوكرانيا قال خلال 24 ساعه خلصت
هذا نحن شهر اربعه عشر من قال لك من قال
لك من قال لك يا دكتور فيصل من قال لك انه
خلال 20 سنه اولا ولا قياده روسيه ولا لا
عسكريه سياسيه لم يتحدوا عن يتحدث عن
الزمن على الاطلاق هذه البروباجان ده هي
بروباجانده غربيه امريكيه على ان روسيا
ارادت ان تحرر تحرر او تصل الى كيف وخارقه
وتحرر كل
اوكرانيا خلال 24 ساعه هذا الكلام مغلوط
وهذا الكلام غير صحيح ولم تتحدث واتحداكم
واتحداكم ان سمعتم اي شخصيه سياسيه او
عسكريه روسيه قالت عن زمن معين انا قلت لك
قبل قليل بهدوء وباعصاب بارده تتقدم الجيش
الروسي ويحرر خطوه خطوه متر مئه متر المهم
اتمنى لا تقاطعني رجاء ومئه متر مئه متر
وفي النهايه وفي النهايه سوف تصل وتتحقق
كل اهداف العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
تفضل
اولاها اهميه كبيره جدا واستراتيجيه
استراتيجيا وعسكريا هذا اولا فاما بالنسبه
للقتله فاعتقد اعتقد فلتذهب يعني قناتكم
الجزيره وترى القتلى الاوكران بالاف
الالاف في هذه المنطقه وهذا ليس من كلامي
بالمناسبه هذه الاحصائيات الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والفرنسيه والبريطانيه
انه تم قتل اكثر من 70 الف اوكرانيا هناك
نازل طبعا نازي نازي انا اتحدث عن عسكريين
النازيين قتلوا هناك اما بالنسبه لماذا
تمسكت اوكرانيا طالما انها ليس ليست ذات
اهميه استراتيجيه هذه المنطقه او المدينه
لماذا تمسكت اوكرانيا بهذه المنطقه
وضحت بسبعين الف انسان اما بالنسبه لروسيا
هي الذات اهميه
ودفعت ثمن نعم ثمن ربما كبير لاحد يعرف
ثمن من اجل ان تسيطر عليها وسيطرت عليها
في نهايه المطاف قالت سناخذ ارتيومس فاخذت
ارتيومس بالاوكرانيه واخذت ارجمس اذا كل
ما تحدث عنه الجنرالات الروس حققوه قالوا
سناخذوا قالوا سناخذ خرسون اخذوا ولو
انسحبوا من جزء من الخرشون قالوا سوف ناخذ
والان تتقدم الجيش الروسي خطوه خطوه وهذا
هو المهم المهم شوف لقلك كلمتين اخر شيء
من يملك نفسا قويا وطويلا
وصبرا اكبر كبيرا هو الذي ينتصر وهذه ميزه
الروس وميزه الجيش الروسي له نفس طويل
وصبر قوي وكبير فاعتقد مصر لا شك لا شك
محالفا للروس جميل جدا دكتور محمد انت قلت
عن الدكتور نزار انه يعيش على المريخ
وهو يقول لك الان انت تعيش على كوكب
المشتري او كوكب الزهره في واقع الامر
لماذا لا ناخذ يعني بدل بدلا دكتور محمد
يعني بدلا بدلا من ان من ان يعني نقول انه
لم يبقى شيء من القوه الروسيه وكذا لماذا
لا نتحدث عن اخر ما انجزته روسيا في باخمت
نعم صمدت باخمت سته اشهر نعم خسر الروس
الكثير من الضحايا لكن في نهايه المطاف
سقطت باخمت والبعض يقول بصراحه يعني في
اول يوم تقرب في زيلينسكي من الجامعه
العربيه ثاني يوم سقطت ضخمه كيف ترد
يا دكتور فيصل تعقيب سريع على ما قاله
الضيف الذي لا اريد ان تستخدم كلمات ثقيله
تصريحات الاوكرانيه ومؤسسه دراسه الحرب
البريطانيه هي قالت عكس ما قالت ضيف هي
تقول بان 70 الف من مرتزقه فاجنر والجيش
الروسي مقبورين الان في باخت الرجاء اي
واحد ممكن يفتح التصريحته ويقراها لذلك
على الاقل نكون شيئا من الصدق اولا ثاني
ما يسميه لكن دكتور محمد
لكن دكتور محمد لماذا لا نقول ان هذه
البروباندا غربيه لماذا لا نقول ان هذه
الارقام بروباندا غربيه
مثلما ان هناك
دكتور فيصل على موضوع التحرير راينا كيف
الروس استقبلوا في اوكرانيا بكيف بالرصاص
راينا كيف الروس تقبل في طبعا في خاركم في
كل المود التي دخلوها الروس المجرمون
واحتلوها خرسون خرج الاوكرانيون
الفيديوهات موجوده في اول مارس بالاعلام
الاوكرانيه لذلك عن اي تحرير الروسيه هي
النازيه الجديده وعندما تتصاعد الجيش
الاوكراني من طرد الروس ودحرهم من خرسون
راينا كيف استقبل الجيش الاوكراني بالورود
هذه اعتقد اي واحد بفتح فيديو ويراها
النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه النفس
الطويل هنا جاءت اف 16 يا دكتور فيصل كي
لا يقوم طبعا نفس طويل عندما علم بوتين
وللعلم الدكتور اعيد عندما بوتين اكثر من
مره صرح بوتا في العام الماضي قال لحد
سبتمبر يجب احتلال كامل الدنباص فطبعا فشل
بوتين في هذا العام تصريحات موجوده قال في
ذكرى طبعا الغزو يجب السيطره على الدم
وفشل وظل بوتين يضع التاريخ تلو الاخر واي
واحد متابعي
اتمنى
صديقي العزيز
يا دكتور يا دكتور انت لو عايز تقرا انت
الان انت الان تقوم بعمليه تضليل المتابع
اي واحد يفتح النت تصريحات بوتين اكثر من
سبع مرات يضع تاريخ ويفشل بوتين الان عجوز
خرف يقوم على دوله مدمره يتناحر بينها
قديره من جهه وطبعا لحظه
للجميع لو تكرمت بدون مقاطعه خلينا نسمع
تفضل انا اعرف انا على الارض اما طبعا
دكتور فيصل انا هنا في كيف موجود وهنا حتى
الان اشلاء الدبابات في اقليم طبعا في
اقليم كلها دخلت عربات وكلها احرقت وحرقت
الى ماذا العجز الروسي الان يبدو اي واحد
يفتح ويرى روسيا كيف الان جلس بوتين
منبوذا في تسعه مايو لم ياتي اليه احد
ليشاركها عرسه وراينا لم يعرض اليوم
بالساحه الحمراء ولا دبابه الا تي 34 من
بواقي الحرب العالميه الثانيه ما يخص
موضوع النفس الطويل لذلك جاءت اف 16
مجموعه السبعه الكبار التي كان بها
زيلينسكي قبل ايام باليابان هل كان يعتقد
بوتين عندما سيغزو اوكرانيا ان ياتي
زيلينسكي ويجلس على كرسي بوتين هذا هو
التاريخ اليوم الان الغرب ايقن بان بوت
يريد ان يطير الامد ويحوله لحرب الاستنزاف
لذلك يمد اوكرانيا بافس 16 التي تحول او
اي تقدم عسكري الروسي الى فاشل النقطه
الرابعه ما يخص حتى الان لم يشطر عليها
فاقنر تعلم جيدا لكي تخرج من امامها اما
ان تخرج والله
ضحكتني حقيقه
لحظه لحظه اما ان تخرج في توابيت وتعلم
توابيت
واعترافاتن نفسه وسمى بوتين الجد الخرف
اما ان تخرج طبعا من باكموت بالتوابيت مصر
وثم يهنئها بوت وتنسحب ماذا حدث سارى لحظه
لحظه حتى الان لم يقدم اي ادله لم يقدم اي
ادله طبعا في ان باخذ من الاحتيال رغم ذلك
باخ متادت مهمتها كامله 14 شهرا والروس
بغبائهم العسكري والسياسي سبعين الف حرق
وقبروا الجيش الاوكراني هذه الفتره حصل
على تشالنجر واليوبارد وطبعا حصل الان على
ستورم
الهجوم
باي شيء واضافه
واضافه الى ان اضافه الى ذلك اضافه ذلك
اوكران اهم شيء اوكرانيا اراد ان تقدم
الغرب ونجحت هذه روسيا لا يجب ان يخشى
منها اعطونا السلاح واوكرانيا انتصرت
عندما اقر الحلفاء منح اوكرانيا بسلاح
العام الماضي العام الاول كان كان طبعا
القتال عفوا
هذا العام طبعا مختلف تماما وروسيا منهكه
الغايه اما موضوع الجامعه العربيه لا
الجامعه العربيه
يعني البعض يقول الان البعض يقول ان الروس
في واقع الامر في في ورطه حقيقيه يعني لم
يعد الجيش الروسي او القياده الروسيه تخشى
على وضعها داخل اوكرانيا بل بدا هناك الان
خشيه داخل روسيا اليوم اليوم بالتحديد
الرئيس الروسي بعظمه لسانه تحدث عن
اختراقات خطيره للقوات الاوكرانيه عبر
الحدود الروسيه تحدث عن ان بعض القوات
الاوكرانيه بدات تتوغل في في مدن
وقرى على الحدود بين البلدين ولا ننسى ما
حصل قبل قبل اسابيع في الكرملين يعني
عندما يتعرض لكرملين رمز الهيبه والجبروت
الروسي
يعني لقصف اوت افر بطائرات مسيره فهذا
تحول خطير تاريخي بكل المقاييس كيف ترد
سارد على سؤالك بكل تاكيد ولكن دعني اعقب
قليلا على بعض الامور التي التي تفضل بها
ضيفك الكريم اولا اعجبتني كلمه انتصرت
اوكرانيا كيف انتصرت لا اعرف ربما يفسر
لنا ذلك فيما بعد كيف انتصرت اوكرانيا
واوكرانيا لم يبقى منها حتى الشعب لم يبقى
في اوكرانيا وجنود اوكرانيون عفوا رجال
اوكرانيون لم يبقى في شواء في الشوارع
كلهم على سقيفه واتحدى ضيفك الكريم اذا
كان يستطيع الخروج الى الشارع ربما يجرونه
مباشره الى الجبهه مباشره هم يصورون ذلك
ليس نحن هذا اولا ثانيا اريد ان اعقب في
روسيا
اما في روسيا اما في روسيا فلم نرى فلم
نرى طوابير بعشرات الالاف من الناس هاربين
من المدن الروسيه خوفا من الالتحاق
بالقوات على التلفزيون بكل تاكيد
برد عليك مباشره انت لم ترى الطوابير
المتطوعه الرجال الذين يتطوعون الان
للدفاع عن بلدهم ايضا لا ترى على كل حال
ولكن اريد ان ابيع عجاله ساجيب بكل تاكيد
ذلك في قمه العشرين في 22 مايو ايار
ارسل الرئيس بوتين هديه الى قمه العشرين
والىنسكي عندما تم تحرير
في نفس اليوم عندما اجتمعوا من اجل تزويد
اوكرانيا
تم اهداء هذا النصر لهم وقال لهم هذه قد
تحررت هذا اولا واخيرا واخيرا تعقيب اخير
مجله فرنسيه اكتويلز تحدثت عن طبعا لسان
خبراء عسكريين فرنسيين بالحرف الواحد
اليوم اليوم هذا الكلام ان عدد القتلى من
جنود القوات الاوكرانيه يعتبر من
المعلومات غير المرغوبه بها وانا اكثر من
نصف الجنود الاوكراني الذي دربتهم فرنسا
وعددهم ما يفوق 15 الف جندي لم يجيبوا على
التليفون وقد تم قتلهم او قتلوا في الجبهه
هذا ليس من عندي فهذا من الخبراء
العسكريين الفرنسيين اما بالنسبه لسئوله
وسؤالك بكل تاكيد الان اجيب اولا لا شك لا
شك ان هناك في داخل روسيا تعرفون اوكران
كثيرون الذين اصلا بقوا في روسيا ومنهم من
هاجر او ترك هذه الاراضي وجاء لروسيا من
خطر الحرب ومن خطر النازيه ولكن تم تجنيد
جزء منهم وهذا كل يوم نراه كل يوم نراه
ونرى كيف ان الاستخبارات الروسيه تقبض على
هذا العميل او ذاك العميل للاستخبار وفي
شغله هذا ليس مجرد نظري هذا اعتراف هؤلاء
طبعا المجندون من قبل الاستخبارات
بريطانيه والامريكيه
والاوكرانيه هم اوكرانيون هذا واحد اما
بالنسبه لاستهداف
الكرملين طبعا يبقى رمز روسيا وافتخار
روسيا بكل تاكيد هذا لا شك وهي طبعا لا شك
انها ضربه ليست سهله طبعا هم لم يستطيعوا
فعل شيء على كل حال ولكن تبقى العمليه
ليست سهله اريد ان اذكركم ان منطاد الصيني
ليس عسكريا اخترق كل الاجواء الامريكيه
وطار من الصين 13 او 12 الف كيلو متر
وصولا الى الى الى لوين جميل اذا هنا لا
يوجد دوله محصنه على الاطلاق في كل العالم
لا لا اخيرا طول بالك يا اخي اما بالنسبه
لهذول اللي اخترقوا الحدود مبارحه البارحه
تم القضاء عليهم بالمطلق بالمطلق اليوم
التقرير وطبعا راينا الفيديوهات
بالفيديوهات نحن بالفيديوهات تم القضاء
عليهم على الاطلاق ولكن هنا السؤال كيف
ولماذا اولا الحدود
الروسيه الاوكرانيه طولها 2250 كيلو متر
هذا اولا ثانيا هي غابات غابات كثيفه جدا
ثالثا لم تكن اصلا مهيئه روسيا تعتبر كانت
اوكرانيا دوله شقيقه ولا يوجد اصلا يعني
هناك قوات على هذه في هذه المناطق فربما
يمكن اختراق هذه المناطق وامص واريد ان
اذكرك بان المكسيكيين بالالاف يخترقون
وامريكا ويدخلون يا اخي جميل جدا امر
طبيعي جميل جدا
لا تكبر الموضوع جميل جدا
هيهات المطاف في نهايه المطاف سوف يتم
القضاء على النازيه في اوكرانيا
وهذا هدف روسي لا يمكن ان تتراجع عنه جميل
جدا جميل جدا دكتور محمد دكتور محمد دكتور
محمد الا تعتقد ان يعني هذا
خلينا نقول يعني هذا هذه المبالغه الان
الغربيه الامريكيه في دعم
الاوكرانيين وتزويدهم بالطائرات
وبالصواريخ البعيده المدى والى ما هنالك
الا تخشون الان من ان تصبح حتى المدن
الاوروبيه في مرمى الجيش الروسي والصواريخ
الروسيه هل تعتقد ان روسيا يمكن ان تصبر
طويلا بعد ان بات عمقها يعني في مرمى
الصواريخ البريطانيه
والامريكيه والى ما هنالك من هذا الكلام
الا تجازفون الا تغامرون ام ان روسيا
برايك غرقت في المستنقع الاوكراني ولم يعد
لها لا حول ولا قوه
شكرا على سؤالك وتعليق على ما قال الضيف
يريد ان فعلا ان يذكرني كلامه بما حدث بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه عندما قامت طبعا
محكمه نور بيرج بمحاكمه النازيين وحاكموا
من كانوا يعملوا في البروبوغاندا النازيه
لاندا الكاذبه هم شركاء بالجريمه موضوع
الحدود اللي بقول عنه طبعا دوله صديقه
انتوا جيتوا تقتلوا شعب ذبحتم طبعا جئتم
الى دوله تهاجموها وتعتبروها شقيقه دكتور
فيصل ان الصور عندي صفحه الفيسبوك منشوره
الفيلق الروسي الحر لم يخرج الى غابه هاجم
نقطه حدوديه روسيه
وجيش حارس الحد الروسي فروك الجرذان نشروا
الصور من داخل معبر حدودي اذا لا عقيده
لهذا الجند الروسي كي يدافع عن حدوده قبل
حوالي شهر حاكم اقليم بلغراد قال ان
الحدود محكمه لا يمكن ان يرها ونرى الان
جيشهم كالجورذان هذه اللحظه قبل قليل بث
فيديو مباشر من داخل خمس قرى من هذا
الاقليم صراحه ضيفك لا علاقه
محمد لم اقاطع انا بس دكتور محمد خليني
اسالك سؤال دكتور محمد
انتم النازيون محمد
في ليبيا
دكتور محمد
الا تغمرون الان
تغمرون الان
مغامر بالعكس
مع اوروبا باختصار
دكتور فيصل روسيا عاريه روسيا خرجت من
نادي الاقوياء روسيا التي في العالم راها
احدى 14 شهرا غير قادر على حسم مع حرب مع
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه كيف ستكون او
يفكر بوتين لمهاجمه حلف الناتو الذي اصبح
31 عضوا الذي يتفوق عليها عددا وعده اليوم
بحر البلطيق اصبح بحيره النيتو اليوم
البحري الروسيه في البلطيق لا تتحرك الا
باذن الناتو اليوم فنلندا تدخل طبعا في
النيت وعليها طبعا القواعد العسكريه اليوم
بدل الخرده الروسيه هنا اصبح ياتي طبعا اف
والدكتور محمد دكتور محمد
دكتور محمد بس دكتور محمد البعض يقول ما
فائده 16 ما فائده طائرات الاف سته عشر
الامريكيه اذا كانت روسيا قد كانت قد دمرت
الكثير من المدرجات والمطارات الاوكرانيه
ويمكن للروس ان يدمروا الاكثر من مما
دمروه من مدرجات من اين ستطير الطائرات
الامريكيه التي ستصلكم بعد اربعه اشهر او
بعد ان يتدرب عليها الطيارون الاوكرانيون
كيف نعم تفضل اولا التدريب بدا التدريب
بدا ثانيا يا دكتور فيصل بيانات وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه كلها كاذبه لو اردنا ان
ناخذ بالقلم والورقه كل ما في اوكرانيا 16
هايبرز لو جمعنا حسبه ورق ما يقولوا
الدفاع الروسيه نرى بانه دمر الفينز سيدي
الكريم انا بام عيني ولا اريد ان افصح
الاماكن زرت مدرجات للطائرات الحربيه
الروسيه في اربع اقاليم انا شفتها بعضها
طبعا الان تم اعاده بناؤها ثانيا روسيا
ولا اوكرانيا قبل عام اليوم اوكرانيا
حاليا طبعا الان الان مدرجات موجوده دكتور
فيصل الان في اكثر من خمس اقاليم اوكرانيه
هنالك مدرجات اوكرانيه سريه بنيت جديدا في
وقت القصف الحالي اليوم الصواريخ الروسيه
لم تعد والاوروبيون عندما
منظومتين فقط ايرستيل المانيه وباتريوت
الامريكيه راوا كيف التناغم بين هاتين
المنظمتين اسقطوا وسلبوا من روسيا واقوى
سلاح لها وهو طبعا صاروخ كنزار الفرس صوتي
اليوم لو راينا كل ما كانت روسيا تتحدث به
من تفوق عسكري كله اليوم جر في اوكرانيا
وكله اليوم فشل لذلك اليوم روسيا ليس
لديها قوه عسكريه ان تهاجم حلف الناتوم
روسيا عاجزه ان تحسم المعركه ولو حتى في
اقليم لوغانسك او زبالوجيا ثالثا اليوم
العقوبات بدات تدق واليوم الماليه الروسيه
تعترف في ابريل الحالي العجز بلغ اكثر من
واحد تريليون روبل اليوم حتى المنظومات
الروسيه التي كانت طبعا اورلان المسيرات
تستخدم كاميرات سامسونج وسوني اليوم روسيا
لا يمكن ان تقادم دوله
30 دول مجتمعه في حين هي طبعا الان عاجزه
ان تقاوم طبعا
دكتورز مهمه جدا لكي تقوم اوكرانيا بضرب
العمق في الاراضي المحتله الاوكرانيه جميل
جدا دكتور دكتور نزار دكتور نزار دكتور
نزار لا شك انك سمعت الاخبار بالامس
مجموعه السبعه الكبار قالوا بالحرف الواحد
نعم لا يمكن لاوكرانيا ان تنضم الى حلف
الاطلس او حلف الناتو الان لكننا سنعطيها
الميزات التي نعطيها لاسرائيل تصور الان
اوكرانيا اصبحت بمنزله اسرائيل من حيث
الحظوه الغربيه يعني سيقدمون لها انت تعلم
ماذا يقدم الغرب لاسرائيل ماذا تقدم
امريكا لاسرائيل الان اوكرانيا ستحصل على
اسلحه وعلى قدوه الولد
المدلل فلا تعتقد ان الغرب الان يتقدم
خطوات كثيره وانتم الان في في الزاويه ولا
ننسى ولا ننسى دكتور نزار لا يجب ان ننسى
ما حصل للجيش الروسي والجيش الاحمر على
ايدي ما يسمى بالمجاهدين الافغان في
افغانستان بصواريخ ستنجر البدائيه فما
بالك الان بعد دخلت الطائرات الامريكيه
والصواريخ العابره للقارات والى ما هنالك
انتم في الزاويه كيف ترد
[موسيقى]
هناك ازد من من يقود من يقود اوروبا هم
المثليون يعني كل يوم بتصرح تصريح بدل ما
يكون دبلوماسي وتصرح بدنا نقتل روسيا بدنا
نضرب روسيا بدنا نهدم ان في دمه الان بدا
يغلي العرق النازج لشولز بدو يحرق الروس
ويقتل الروس اذا البلونيون الذين يوميا
يتحدثون ولكن هنا امر مهم جدا انا اريد
جمله واحده بجمله واحده
ماذا تريد لماذا لا يرسل الناتو قواته
وشبابه الى اوكرانيا ليقاتلوا الروس لماذا
يقاتلون بالشباب الاوكرانيين المساكين
الذين يجرونهم الى المعركه بدون تدريب
ويقتلونهم لم يبقى رجال في اوكرانيا يا
صديقي يبقى رجال جميل جدا وصلت الفكره
جميل جدا دكتور محمد دكتور محمد باختصار
باختصار
اين تتجه الان الحرب في اوكرانيا بعد ان
كشر الغرب عن انيابه وقال لكم انتم بمنزله
اسرائيل
وسنقدم لكم كل ما تحلمون به من سلاح
باختصار باختصار انتهى الوقت
باختصار باختصار اوكرانيا اثبتت الغرب بان
اوكرانيا مهمه للغرب بقدر ما الغرب مهم
لاوكرانيا اوكرانيا اثبت بانه منذ ان تاسس
حلف النيتو من سبعين عاما هدفه الاساسي
ولكنه لم يشتبك لم يشتبك لم يشتبك لم
يشتبك يوما ما مع النيتو الا جيش واحد وهو
الجيش الاوكراني عندما راى الاوروبيون ما
يمكن ان تقدمه اوكرانيا من حمايه الامن
الغربي اليوم الاوروبيون يفتحون المخازن
لسببين السبب الاول اوكرانيا تدافع عن
نفسها وعن اراضيها وعن شعبها ضد الغزاء
الروس ثانيا لانهم اصبحوا يروا بانه كسر
روسيا في اوكرانيا سيعيد بناء النظام
العالمي الجديد وسيضع روسيا في خانتها وفي
مقامها الحقيقي وراوا انه الجيش الوحيد
يتحدى روسيا هو الجيش الاوكراني الاوروبا
الاوروبيون استطاعوا ان ينتزعوا انتصارا
كبيرا بضعف فنلندا واهداف روسيا لم تتحقق
ابدا بعد اليوم كذلك اليوم الان لاتفاق
تحويل اوكرانيا الى قلعه مهمه جدا
اوكرانيا في المقابل تطلب مقابل لا نريد
ان نكون عضويه ناتو على الورق نريد ان
نكون
بالفعل اعطونا السلاح وسوف نريكم اشكرك
جزيلا
الاوكرانيه ضربت قاعده انتهى الوقت
الدكتور محمد دكتور محمد
لحظه القوات
لحظه جمله جمله واحده باختصار القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه وضعت روسيا بحجمها
الحقيقي اشكرك جزيل الشكر المشاهدين
الكرام لم يبقى لنا نشكر ضيفينا من موسكو
الدكتور نزربوش ومن كيف الدكتور محمد فرج
الله
نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك
الحين هو فيصل القاسم يحييكم من الدوحه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]